all right welcome back everyone
day two
got a lot we want to accomplish today
what I have on the screen right now is
the home base for the course this is our
public website and you could think of it
as kind of a hub for everything that
you'll need in the course you can see
along the top here we've got some policy
Pages there's a whole page on projects
there's a page that provides an index of
background materials
YouTube
screencasts slides Hands-On materials in
case you need to fill in some background
stuff notice also I do a podcast that
actually began in this course last year
and I found it so rewarding that I just
continued doing it all year and so new
episodes continue to appear if you have
ideas for guests for this podcast feel
free to suggest them I'm always looking
for exciting people to interview and I
think the back episodes are also really
Illuminating
that's along the top then over here on
the left you've got one stop shopping
for the various systems that we have to
deal with you've got our Ed forum for
discussion if you're not in there let us
know we can get you signed up
canvas is your home for the screencasts
and also the quizzes and I guess there's
some other stuff there grade scope is
where you'll submit the main assignments
including your project work and also
enter the bake offs
and then we have our course GitHub and
that is the course code that will be
depending on for the assignments and
that I hope you can build on for the
original work that you do
if you need to reach us you can use the
discussion forum but we also have this
staff email address that is vastly
preferred to writing to us individually
it really helps us manage the workload
and know what's happening if you either
ping us on the discussion forum private
post public post whatever or use that
Staff address
in the middle of this page here we've
got links to all the materials the First
Column is slides and stuff like that and
also notebooks the middle column its
core readings mostly I'm not
presupposing that you will manage to do
all of this reading because there is a
lot of it but these are important and
rewarding papers and so at some point in
your life you might want to immerse
yourselves in them but I'm hoping that I
can be your trusted guide through that
literature
and then on the right you have the
assignments
that's the website
um questions comments anything I could
clear up I have a Time budgeted later to
review the policies and required work in
a bit more detail but if there are
questions now I'm happy to take them
yes for the quizzes are the quizzes
doable on the day that they become
available or do we need
like the course material all the way up
through
that is a good question it's going to
depend on your background but in the
worst case if this is all brand new to
you you might not feel like you can
confidently finish the quiz until that
final lecture in the unit like this one
is all about Transformers all of the
answers are embedded in this handout
here
um but if but if you want to hear it
from me you might not hear that until
next Thursday but that gives you another
five days
yes
past projects are available there
right that must be here I think I've got
an index of past projects behind a
protected link which will depend on you
being enrolled if you're not enrolled we
can get you past that little hurdle but
I did get permission to release some of
them so somewhere on this page is a link
to X oh there it is
exemplary projects there's another list
at the GitHub
projects.md page which is also linked
somewhere in here of published work and
that's stuff you could download the
private link gives you the actual course
submission that could be an interesting
exercise to compare the paper they did
in here with the thing they actually
published and I'll emphasize again that
that will be interesting because of how
much work it typically takes to go from
a class project to something that makes
it onto the ACL anthology
but that's of course an exciting Journey
oh yeah and if you haven't already do
this course setup it's very lightweight
you get your Computing environment set
up to use our code and actually this is
a sign of The Changing Times I also
exhort you to sign up for a bunch of
services collab and maybe consider
getting a pro account for thirty dollars
over the course of the entire quarter
you could get a lot more compute on
collab including gpus also the Amazon
versions
um Sage maker Studio
uh and in addition openai account and
cohere account both of those have free
tiers for cohere you get really rate
limited and for open AI they give you
five dollars uh you could consider
spending a little bit more I do think
you could do all our coursework for
under those amounts and I think that for
open AI you could still have lots of
accounts if you wanted to uh each one
getting five dollars it used to be 18
and now it's five so we know what's
coming
um but but embrace it while you can also
I'll say um pretty well confident that
we'll get a bunch of uh credits from AWS
educate for you to use ec2 machines
um so more details about that in a
little bit
okay so if you want to follow along
let's head to this one this is our
slideshow from last time and I do just
want to review some things what we did
last time is I tried to immerse Us in
this weird and wonderful moment for AI
and give you a sense for how we got here
and then we talked about the first two
units Transformers and retrieval
augmented in context learning I think
that is all wonderful stuff I expect you
all to do lots of creative and cool
things in that space But it's important
for me to continue this slideshow
because there is more to our field than
just those big language models and
prompting and there are lots of
important ways to contribute beyond that
so let me take a moment and just give
you an indication of what I have in mind
there
our third main course unit I've called
compositional generalization this is
brand new we're going to focus on the
cogs Benchmark which is a relatively
recent synthetic data set that is
designed to stress test whether models
have really learned systematic solutions
to language problems so the way cogs
works is we have essentially a semantic
parsing task the input is a sentence
like Lena gave the bottle to John
and the task is learn how is to learn
how to map those sentences to their
logical form which are these logical
representations down here
the interesting thing about about cogs
is that they've posed hard
generalization tasks for example in
training you might get to see examples
where Lena here is in subject position
and then at test time you see Lena in
object position
or at train time you might see Paula as
a name but in isolation and the task is
to have the system learn how to deal
with Paula as a subject of a sentence
like Paula painted a cake
or object PP to subject PP so at train
time you see M8 the cake on the table
where on the table is inside the direct
object of the sentence and then at test
time you see the cake on the table
burned where on the table is now a
subject
these seem like dead simple
generalization tasks right and the
sentences are very simple
but here's the punch line
this is a kind of accumulated
leaderboard of a lot of entries for cogs
and if you look all the way on the right
you can see systems are doing pretty
well it is impressive that they can go
from these free form sentences into
those very ornate logical forms okay but
look at this column
this is a column of zeros object PP to
subject PP it looked really simple right
that's just the task of learning from
Emma ate the cake on the table and
predicting the cake on the table burned
why are these all these brand new
systems getting zero on this split
that shows first of all that this is a
hard problem now we are going to work
with a variant that we created of cogs
called recogns This was done with my
student zenwoo and Chris Manning it's
brand new work
we think that in part all those zeros
derive from there being some artifacts
in cogs so it was made kind of
artificially hard and also artificially
easy in some ways so in this class we're
going to work with recogns which has
done some systematic meaning per
reserving transformations to the
original to create a new data set that
we think is fairer but it still remains
incredibly hard systems can get traction
where before they were getting zero so
we know their signal and we have more
confidence that this is testing
something about semantics and then the
punch line Remains the Same this is
incredibly hard for our systems even our
best systems
there needs to be some kind of
breakthrough here for us to get our
systems to do well even on these
incredibly simple sentences
so I am eager to see what you all do
with this problem you're seeing a
picture here of the kind of best we
could do which is a little bit better
than what was in the literature
previously but certainly not a solved
task
right so that will culminate in this
homework and bake off our third one
from there the course work opens up into
your projects we're done with the
regular assignments and we go through
the rhythm of lit review experiment
protocol which is a special document
that kind of lays down the nuts and
bolts of what you're going to do for
your paper and then the final paper
itself
uh in the spirit of that what we do in
our course together is think about
topics that will supercharge your own
final project papers and the first topic
that comes to mind for me there is
better and more diverse benchmarks we
need measurement instruments to get
reliable estimates of how well our
systems are doing and that implies
having good benchmarks in this context I
really like to invoke this famous
quotation from the Explorer Jacques
Cousteau he said a water and air the two
essential fluids on which all life
depends that's data sets for our field
and you can see here that Cousteau did
continue have become Global garbage cans
that might concern us about what's
happening with our data sets I don't
think it's that bad but still you could
have that in the back of your mind that
we need these data sets we create to be
reliable high quality instruments
and the reason for that is that we ask
so much of our data sets we use them to
optimize models when we train on them we
use them crucially and this is
increasingly important to evaluate our
models our biggest language models that
are getting all the headlines how well
are they actually doing we need data
sets for that we use it to compare
models to enable new capabilities via
training and testing to measure progress
as a field it's kind of our fundamental
barometer for this and of course for
basic scientific inquiry into language
and the world this is a long and
important list and it shows you that
data sets are really Central to what
we're doing
and so I'm sort of exhorting you as you
can tell to think about data sets
especially ones that would be powerful
as evaluation tools in the context of
this course I am genuinely worried about
the new Dynamic where we are evaluating
these big language models essentially on
Twitter where people have screenshots of
some fun cases that they saw and we all
know that we're not seeing a full
representative sample of the inputs
we're seeing the worst and the best and
it's impossible to piece together a
scientific picture from that my own my
student Omar khattab recently observed I
think this is very wise that we have
moved into this era in which designing
systems might be really easy it might be
a matter of writing a prompt but
figuring out whether it was a good
system is going to get harder and harder
and for that we need lots of evaluation
data sets
right you could think about this this
slide that I showed you from before we
have this Benchmark saturation with all
of these systems now increasingly
quickly getting above our estimate of
human performance but I asked you to be
cynical about that as a measure of human
performance right another perspective on
this slide could be that our benchmarks
are simply too easy because it is not
like if you interacted with one of these
systems even the most recent ones it
would feel super human to you
partly what we're seeing here is a
remnant of the fact that until very
recently our evaluations had to be
essentially machine tasks not human
tasks and we had humans do machine tasks
to get a measure of human performance
maybe we're moving into a new and more
exciting era
we're going to talk about adversarial
testing I've been involved with the data
bench effort this is a kind of Open
Source effort to develop data sets that
are going to be really hard for the best
of our models and I think that's a
wonderful dynamic as well
right and that kind of leads into this
related topic of us having more
meaningful evaluations here's a
fundamental thing that you might worry
about throughout artificial intelligence
all we care about is performance for
these systems some notion of accuracy
I've put this under the heading of
strathearn's law when a measure becomes
a Target it ceases to be a good measure
if we have this consensus that all we
care about is accuracy we know what will
happen everyone in the field Will hill
climb on accuracy and we know from
strathearn's law that that will distort
the actual rate of progress by
diminishing everything else that could
be important to thinking about these
these AI systems
relatedly like this is a wonderful study
from birhane at all I've selected a few
of the values encoded in ml research
which they did Via a very extensive
literature survey and kind of
impressionistically here's the list at
the top
dominating everything else you have an
obsession with performance as I said
then way down on the list though in
second place you have efficiency and
things like explainability
applicability in the real world
robustness as I go farther down on the
list here the ones that are colored
there they actually should be in the
tiniest of type because if you think
about the fields actual values as
reflected in the literature you find
that these things are getting almost no
play I think things are looking up
but it's still the case that it's wildly
skewed toward performance but those
things that I have down there in purple
and orange beneficence beneficence
privacy fairness and Justice those are
incredibly important things and more and
more important as these systems are
being deployed deployed more widely and
so we have to Via our practices and what
we hold to be valuable Elevate these
other principles and you all could start
to do that by thinking about proposing
evaluations that would Elevate them that
could be tremendously exciting and the
final Point here is that we could also
have kind of a move toward leaderboards
that Embrace more aspects of this again
to help us move away from the obsession
on performance we should have
leaderboards that kind of score us along
many dimensions in this context I've
really been inspired by work that Colin
did on what he calls dinoscoring which
is a proposal for that for how to
synthesize across a lot of different
measure Dimensions to give you a quick
illustration here I have a table where
the rows are question answering systems
and the columns are different things we
could measure just a sample of them
performance throughput memory fairness
robustness we could add other dimensions
with the current Dyna scoring that
you're seeing here where most of the
weight is put on performance that
duberta system is the winner in this
leaderboard competition
okay but that's standard but what if we
decided that we cared much more about
fairness for these systems so we
adjusted the Dyna scoring here to put
five unfairness keep a lot on
performance but diminish the kind of
other measures there well now the
electoralarge system is in first place
which one was the true winner I think
the answer is that there is no true
winner here what this shows is that all
of our leaderboards are reflecting some
ordering of our preferences and when we
pick one we are instilling a particular
set of values on the whole Enterprise
but this is also creating space for us
this is I think part of Cowan's vision
for Dyna scoring that we could design
leaderboards that were attuned to the
things that we want to do in the world
via the waiting and the columns that we
chose and evaluate systems on the on
that basis
yeah
what is fairness to you in this field
mean how do you measure something like
that what is fairness yeah well that's a
whole nother aspect to this so if we're
going to start to measure these
Dimensions like we're going to have a
column for fairness we better be sure
that we know what's behind that and I
can tell you there needs to be a lot
more work on our measurement devices our
benchmarks for assessing fairness
because all of those things are
incredibly nuanced multi-dimensional
Concepts and so the idea would be to
bring that in as well yeah throughput
memory maybe those are straightforward
but fairness is going to be a
challenging one but that's not to say
that it's not incredibly important
thank you
and then finally to really inspire you I
do feel like this is the first time I
could say this in this course I think
we're moving into an era in which our
evaluations can be much more meaningful
than they ever were before right
assessment today or yesterday is really
one-dimensional that's the performance
thing I mentioned it's largely
insensitive to the context we always
pick F1 or something as the only thing
regardless of what we're trying to
accomplish in the world the terms are
largely set by us researchers right we
say it's F1 and everyone kind of follows
suit because we're supposed to be the
experts on this and it's often very
opaque
and tailored to machine tasks I've
already complained about that are
estimates of human performance being
very different from what you would think
that phrase means
in this new future that we could start
right now our assessments could
certainly be high dimensional and fluid
I showed you a glimpse of that with the
Dyna scoring I think that's incredible
it could also in turn be highly
sensitive to the context that we're in
if we care about fairness and we care
about efficiency and we put those Above
Performance we're going to get a very
different prioritization of the systems
and so forth and so on
right and then in turn the terms of
these evaluations could be set not by us
researchers who are doing our very
abstract thing but rather the people who
are trying to get value out of these
systems the people who have to interact
with them
and then the judgments could ultimately
be made by the users right they could
decide which system they want to choose
based on their own expressed preferences
and then in turn maybe we could have our
evaluations be much more at the level of
human tasks as opposed so right now for
example we might insist that some human
labelers choose a particular label for
an ambiguous example and then we assess
how well they they how much agreement
they have whereas the human thing is to
discuss and debate right to have a
dialogue about what the right label is
in the face of ambiguity and context
dependence well now we could have that
kind of evaluation right maybe we
evaluate systems on their ability to
adjudicate in a human-like way on what
the label should be
hard to imagine before but now probably
something that you could toy around with
a little bit with one of these large
language model apis right now if you
wanted
and I think we could really Embrace that
I have a couple more topics but let me
pause there do people have thoughts
questions insights about
benchmarks and evaluation
I hope you're seeing that it's a wide
open area for final projects yeah is
there more of a move to like get like
specialists in other fields like like
for example like Linguistics or like
related things to like help
what a wonderful question you asked is
there a move to have more experts
participate in evaluation I hope the
answer is yes but let's make the answer
yes that would be the point right
because what we want is to provide the
world with tools and Concepts that would
allow domain experts people who actually
know what's going on in the domain we're
trying to use this AI technology to make
these decisions and make adjustments and
so forth based on what's working and
what isn't yeah that should be
our goal and then what we as researchers
can do is provide things like what Colin
provided with Dyna scoring which is the
intellectual infrastructure to allow
them to do that yeah
and then you all probably have lots of
domain expertise that kind of intersects
with what we're doing but maybe off it
comes from other fields and so you could
participate as nlu researcher and as
domain expert to do a paper that Embrace
both aspects of this and maybe you
propose a kind of metric that you think
really works well for your field of
Economics or sociology or whatever
you're studying right yeah Health
Medicine all these things incredibly
important
so another hand go up yeah
and one of the challenges we're going to
face was just really expensive to
collect human or more sophisticated
labels as an example there's a paper
that came up recently met Paul where
they trained or actually really just
tuned uh the vanilla them to respond to
medical student or medicine medical
questions from USMLE and other medicine
related exams they also had a section
for long long form answers the in short
form answers you know it's a multiple
choice they can figure it out the long
form answers they actually had doctors
evaluating them and that's really
expensive they could only collect so
many labels even you know the large
Staffing doctors so I think the balance
between I mean calculating click-through
is super easy it's just counting but
evaluating how valuable a search result
is that requires a human that's a little
more expensive I'm curious how we can
balance the cost
yeah the issue of costs is going to be
unavoidable for us I think we should
confront it as a group This research has
just gotten more expensive and that's
obviously distorting who can participate
in what we value it's another thing I
could discuss under this rubric for your
particular question though I remain
optimistic because I think we are in an
era now in which you could do a
meaningful evaluation of a system with
no training data and rather just a few
dozen let's say a hundred examples for
assessment if you're careful about how
you use it that is if you don't develop
your system on it and so forth but even
if you say okay I'm gonna have a hundred
for development on a hundred that I keep
for a final evaluation to really get a
sense for how my system performs on new
data that's only 200 examples and I feel
like that's manageable
um
even if we need experts and the point
would be that that might be money well
spent it might be that if we can get
some experts to provide the 200 cases we
have a really reliable measurement tool
I could never have said this 10 years
ago because 10 years ago the norm was to
have 50 000 training instances and 5 000
test instances and now your cost concern
really kicks in
but for the present moment I feel like a
few meaningful cases could be worth a
lot and you all could construct those
data sets again before I used to give
the advice don't create your own data
set in this class you'll run out of time
but now I can give the advice no if you
have some domain expertise in the Life
Sciences or something and you want a
data set
create one to use for assessment it'll
shape your system design but that could
be healthy as well
another big theme in explainability
okay and this also relates to our
increased impact if we're going to
deploy these models out in the world it
is really important that we understand
them right now we do a lot of Behavioral
testing that is we come up with these
exam these test cases and we see how
well the model does but the problem
which is a deep problem of kind of
scientific induction is that you can
never come up with enough cases and the
world is a diverse and complex place and
no matter how many things you dreamed up
when you were doing the research if you
deploy your system it will encounter
things that you never anticipated
and if all you've done is behavioral
testing you might feel very nervous
about this because you might have
essentially no idea what it's going to
do on new cases the mission of
explainability research should be to go
one layer deeper and understand what is
happening inside these models so that we
have a sense for how they'll generalize
to new cases it's a very challenging
thing because we're thinking about these
enormous and Incredibly opaque models
and there is you can even find people
saying in the literature that they're
skeptical that we can ever understand
what's happening with these systems but
I am optimistic they are closed
deterministic systems they may be
complex but we're smart we can figure
out what they have learned I really have
confidence in this and the importance of
this is really that we have these
broader societal goals we want to
systems that are reliable and safe and
trustworthy and we want to know where we
can use them and we want them to be free
from bias and it seems to me that all of
these questions depend us on us having
some true analytic guarantees about
model behaviors it seems very hard for
me to say trust me my model is not
biased along some Dimension if I don't
even have any idea how it works the best
I could say is that it wasn't biased in
some evaluations that I ran but I just
emphasize for you that that's very
different from
being evaluated by the world where a lot
of things could happen that you didn't
anticipate
we'll talk about a lot of different
explanation methods I think that these
methods should be human interpretable
that is we don't want low-level
mathematical explanations of how the
models work we want this expressed at
human level Concepts so that we can
reason about about these systems
and we also want them to be faithful to
the underlying model we don't want to
fabricate human interpretable but
inaccurate explanations of the model we
want to we want them to be true to the
underlying systems these are two very
difficult standards to meet together
I can make them human interpretable if
they if I offer you no guarantees of
faithfulness right but then I'm just
tricking myself and you I can make them
faithful by making them very technical
and low level we could just talk about
all the Matrix multiplications we want
but that's not going to provide a human
level insight into how the models are
working so together though we need to
get methods that are good for both of
these right concept level understanding
of the causal dynamics of these systems
we'll talk about a lot of different
explanation methods I'll just do this
quickly train test that is the
behavioral Thing Remains very important
for the field we'll talk about probing
which was an early and very influential
and very ambitious attempt to understand
the hidden representations of our models
we'll talk about attribution methods
these are kind of ways to assign
importance to different parts of the
representations of these models both
input and output and also their internal
representations and then we're going to
talk about methods that depend on active
manipulations of model internal States
and you you'll be able to tell that I
strongly favor the active manipulation
approach because I think that that's the
kind of approach that can give us causal
insights and also richly characterize
what the models are doing and that's
more or less the two desiderata that I
just mentioned for these methods
but there's value to all of these things
and we'll talk about all of them and
you'll get Hands-On with all of them and
all of them can be wonderful for your
analysis sections of your final papers
we might even talk about interchange
intervention training which is when you
use explainability methods to actually
push the models to become better more
systematic more reliable maybe less
biased along Dimensions that you care
about
that's my review of the core things
questions or comments I have a few more
kind of more low-level things about the
course to do now yeah I know we're going
to get into all of the explanation
methods in a lot of detail later on but
can you give a quick example just so
that we have any imagination of what
they are
probing is training supervised
classifiers on internal representations
and this was just a cool thing to say
hey I'll just look at layer 3 column
four of my birth representation does it
encode information about animacy or part
of speech
uh and the answer seems to be yes
and I think that was really eye-opening
that the you know even if your task was
sentiment analysis you might have
learned latent structure about animacy
that's getting closer to the human level
concept stuff problem with probing is
that you have no guarantee that that
information about animacy here has any
causal impact on the Model Behavior it
could be just kind of something that the
model learned by the by
uh attribution methods have the kind of
reverse problem they can give you some
causal guarantees that you know this
neuron plays this particular role in the
input output Behavior but it's a usually
just a kind of scalar value it's like
0.3 and you say well what does the 0.3
mean and you say it means that it's that
much important but nothing like oh is it
animentory none of those human level
things and then I think the active
manipulation thing which is like doing
lots of brain surgeries on your model
uh can provide the benefits of both
probing and attribution causal insights
but also a deep understanding of the
what the representations are
and there's a whole family of those it's
a very exciting part of the literature
yeah
I'm going back to cogs so I guess why
walk or generalization like why can't we
just prompt a language model of a word
that we've never seen before and kind of
like try and induce some form of if you
see it in the subject position get it to
position in the object and see how well
it does that oh yeah no so four cogs for
your original system it could be that
you try to prompt a language model
uh Zen did a bunch of that as part of
the research it was only okay
but maybe there's a version of that
where you prompt in the right way with
the right kind of instructions and then
it does solve cogs that would be
wonderful because that would suggest to
me that that those models whatever model
you prompted has internal
representations that are systematic
enough to have kind of a notion of
subject and a notion of object and verb
and all of that linguistic stuff and
that would be very exciting
yeah the cool thing about cogs is that I
think it's a pretty reliable measurement
device for making such claims
this discussion to languages other than
English like I wonder if they're like
efficiently concerned about the very
tight coupling between you know the
properties of English as a language and
all our advancement in independently
well I mean I hope that a lot of you do
projects on multilingual NLP low
resource settings and so forth
and I think in a way we live in a golden
age for that research as well there's
more research on more languages than
there were 10 years ago and that's
certainly a positive development the
downside is that it's all done with
multilingual representations
multilingual bird and so forth and they
tend to do much better on English tasks
than every other task So that obviously
feels like sub-optimal
um but again that's the same story of
like sudden progress with a lot of mixed
feelings that I have about a lot of
these topics
thank you
in the interest of time let's press on a
little bit
I think I just wanted to skip to the
course mechanics this is at the website
but there it is that's the breakdown of
required pieces you can see that it has
a kind of strong emphasis toward the
three parts that are related to the
final project
but the homeworks are also really
important and the quiz is less so
but I think they're important enough
that you'll take them seriously
uh it's fully asynchronous it's
wonderful to see so many of you here and
I am eager to interact with you here if
possible but also on Zoom for office
hours and stuff please attend office
hours if you just want to chat one of my
favorite games to play in office hours
is a group comes with three project
ideas and I rank them from least to most
or most to least viable for the course
it's a fun game for me and I think it
always illuminates some things about the
the problems
all right then we have continuous
evaluation so you have the three
assignments the quizzes and then the
project work there's no final exam just
the we want you to be focused on the
final project at that point
I think I'll leave this aside we can
talk about the grading of the original
systems a bit later
and then you have the project work some
links here exceptional final projects
and some guidance these are the two
documents I mentioned before
uh I'll just say again that this is the
most important part of the course to me
and the thing that's special and I'll
say again also we have this incredibly
accomplished teaching team this year
diverse interests and they all have done
incredible research on their own I've
learned a ton from them and from their
work and I encourage you to do the same
so seek them out in office hours and
um and you know take advantage of their
mentorship for the work you do
and then here are some crucial course
links kind of covered that before the
quizzes I think I've covered as well
and these policies are all at the
website
um
right and so the setup do that if you
haven't already make sure you're in the
discussion forum we want you to be
connected with the kind of ongoing
discourse for the class do quiz zero as
soon as you can so you know your rights
and responsibilities and then I think
right now we should check out the
homework the sentiment homework
to make sure you're oriented around that
before we dive into Transformers
questions about that stuff
it's all at the website but I've kind of
evoked it for you in case it raised any
issues
all right let's look briefly at the
first homework I feel like we should
kick it off somehow and it is maybe an
unusual mode for homeworks so feel free
to ask questions this is kind of cool so
this link will take you to the GitHub
uh which I think you're probably all set
up with on your home computers but you
might want to work with this in the
cloud and though so this works well so
you could just click click like open in
collab
and
I think I've done a pretty good job of
getting you so that it will set itself
up
with the installs that you need in the
course repo and so forth I would
actually be curious to know where there
are bumps along the road to getting this
to just work out of the box in collab I
do encourage this because if you're
ambitious you'll probably want gpus and
this is a good inexpensive way to get
them
uh it's also a pretty nice environment
to do the work in
zoom in here
along the left you can see the outline
and that's actually kind of a good place
to start so we're doing multi-domain
sentiment and what I mean by that is
you're encouraged to work with three
data sets Dyna sent round one dynascent
round two and the Stanford sentiment
Tree Bank these are all sentiment tasks
and they all have ternary labels
positive negative and neutral but I am
not guaranteeing you that those labels
are aligned in the semantic sense in
fact I think that the SST labels are a
bit different from the dynasent ones
but certainly the underlying data are
different because dynascent is like
product reviews and Stanford sentiment
Tree Bank is movie reviews
but there are further things so dynasant
round one is hard examples that we
harvested from the world from the Yelp
academic data set
whereas dinascent round two is actually
annotators working on the dynabench
platform which I mentioned just a minute
ago trying to fool a really good
sentiment model
so the Dyna sent round two examples are
hard they involve like non-literal
language use and sarcasm and other
things that we know challenge current
day models
so you have these three data sets and
then for the there are really two main
questions for the first question I'm
just pushing you to develop a simple
linear model with sparse feature
representations this is a kind of more
traditional mode background if you need
a refresher on this this is a chance to
get it if you feel stuck on this
question I think we should talk about
how to get you up to speed for the
course but for a lot of you especially
if you've been immersed in NLP this
should be a pretty straightforward
question
it leads to a pretty good system so you
do a feature function you write a
function for training models and a
function for assessing models
for each one of these questions what you
do is complete a function that I started
there is not a lot of coding this is
mainly about starting to build your own
original system
and for every single one of these
questions there's a test that you can
run
I like unit tests a lot I think we
should all write more unit tests the
advantage of the test for me is that if
there was any unclarity about my own
instructions the test probably clears
them up and you also get a guarantee
that if your code passes the test you're
in good shape
more or less the same tests run on grade
scope so when you upload the notebook if
you got a clean bill of health at home
you'll probably do fine on grade scope
and if you don't it might be because the
great scope Auto grader has a bug
let me know about that those things
always feel like they're just barely
functioning
but the idea is that you know this is
really not about me evaluating you this
is about you exercising the relevant
muscles and building up Concepts that
will let you develop your own systems
and I'm just trying to be a trusted
guide for you on that
so you do some coding and you have
through these three questions here and
the result of doing those three
questions is that you have something
that could be the basis for your
original system it'd be pretty cool by
the way if some people competed using
just sparse linear models to show the
Transformers that there's still
competition out there
uh
so that's the first question and then
the second one is the same way except
now we're focused on Transformer fine
tuning which is our main focus for this
unit
um
I have a question here that pushes you
to understand how these models tokenize
data
it's really different from the old mode
you'll learn some hugging face code and
you'll also learn some Concepts
and then I have a question that pushes
you to understand what the
representations are like we're going to
talk about them abstractly here you'll
be Hands-On with them
and then finally you're going to finish
up writing a pi torch module where you
fine-tune Bert
and that is Step One to a really
incredible system I'm sure
and I've actually written the interface
for you so that given the course code
and everything else the interfaces for
these things are pretty straightforward
to write all you have to do is write the
module and for completing the homework
questions you don't actually need heavy
duty Computing at all because you don't
do anything heavy duty
but when you get to the original system
that might be where you want to train a
big monster model and figure out how to
work with the computational resources
that you have to get that done
this notebook is using Tiny Bird which
is small but you still need a GPU to do
the work so you'll still want to be on
collab or something like that
and then I don't know how ambitious
you're going to get for your original
system you can tell that I'm trying to
lead you toward using question one and
question two for your original system
but it's not required and if you want to
do something where you just prompt gpt4
maybe you'll win I don't know
I'm up for anything it does need to be
an original system so you can't just
download somebody else's code and if all
you did was a very boring prompt
structure you wouldn't get a high grade
on your original system we're trying to
encourage you to think creatively and
explore
and then the final thing is you just
enter this in a bake off and really that
just means grabbing an unlabeled data
set from the web and adding a column
with predictions in it
and then you upload that when you submit
your work to grade scope
and then when everyone's submissions are
in we'll reveal the scores and there'll
be some winners
and we'll give out prizes I'm optimistic
that we're going to have ECT ec2 codes
as prizes that's always been fun because
if you win a Bake Off you get a little
bit more compute resources for your next
big thing
um yeah they they become they don't want
to hand out these codes anymore like
they used to because Cloud compute is so
important now but I think I have uh an
arrangement in place to get some and by
the way we give out prizes for the best
systems and the most creative systems
and we have even given out prizes for
the lowest scoring systems because if
that was a cool thing that should have
worked and didn't I feel like you did a
service to all of us by going down that
route and that deserves a prize
as a trying to have a multi-dimensional
leaderboard here right even as we rank
all of you according to the performance
of your systems
that's my overview questions or comments
or anything
all right
I propose then
that we go to Transformers
so download the the handout and by the
way these should be really good so these
slides you'll get a version with fewer
overlays to make it more browsable all
of these things up here are links
so um
oops
so if you click on these bubbles you can
go to directly to that part and you can
see that this is a kind of outline of
this unit
and then there's also a good table of
contents with good labels so if you need
to find things in what I admit is a very
large deck that should make it easier to
do that and you can also track our
progress as we move through these things
so we Dive In
guiding ideas
what is happening with these contextual
representations
okay this one slide here used to take
two weeks for this course
and I've been trying to convey this
we've stopped doing that the background
materials are still at the website it
was also the first two weeks of cs224n
we did them before they did them in
ccs224n back before natural language
understanding was all the rage but they
get there first now and it is a more
basic course I'm saying they do glove
word to VEC and we're going to dive
right into Transformers here is my one
slide summary of this
back in the old old days the dawning of
the statistical revolution in NLP
the way we represented examples let's
say words for this case was with
feature-based sparse representations and
what I mean by that is that if you
wanted to represent a word of a language
you might write a feature function that
says okay yes or no on it being
referring to an animate thing yes or no
on it ending in the characters ing yes
or no on it uh mostly being used as a
verb and so forth and so on and so all
these little feature functions would end
up giving you really long vectors of
essentially ones and zeros
that were kind of hand designed and that
would give you a perspective on a bunch
of the dimensions of the word you were
trying to represent
that lasted for a while and then it kind
of started to get replaced
pre-word to vac and glove with methods
like Point wise Mutual information or TF
IDF
these methods had long been recognized
as fundamental in the field of
information retrieval especially TF IDF
as a main representation technique for
finding relevant documents for queries
took a while for NLP people to realize
that they would be valuable but what you
start to see here is that instead of
writing all those feature functions I'll
just keep track of co-occurrence
patterns in large collections of text
and PMI and TF IDF I do this do this
essentially just by counting and then
re-weighting some of the counts but
really it is the rawest form of
distributional representation
that could kind of got replaced or this
is sort of simultaneous in an
interesting way but you have paired with
PMI and TF IDF methods like a principal
components analysis SVD which is some
sometimes called latent semantic
analysis LDA which is latent dirichlet
allocation a topic modeling technique
it's a whole family of these things that
are essentially taking count data and
giving you reduced dimensional versions
of that count data and the power of
doing that is really that you can
capture higher order Notions of
co-occurrence not just what I as a word
co-occurred with but also the sense in
which I might co-occur with words that
co-occur with the things I co-occur with
your kind of second order neighbors and
you can imagine traveling out into this
representational neighborhood here
and that turns out to be very powerful
because a lot of semantic affinities
come not from just being neighbors with
something but rather from that whole
network of things co-occurring with each
other
and what these methods do is take all
that count data and compress it in a way
that loses some information but also
captures those Notions of similarity
the final step which might actually be
the kind of final step in this
literature we're learned dimensionality
reduction things autoencoders work to
vac and glove
and this is where you might start with
some count data but you have some
machine learning algorithm that learns
how to compute
dense learned representations from that
count data
so kind of like step three infused with
more of what we know of as a machine
learning now
and I say it might be the end because I
think now
for anything that you would do with this
mode you would probably just use
contextual representations so this is
the full story perhaps
and then here's the review if you want
right and I think it is important to
understand this both the history but
also the technical details to really
deeply understand what I'm about to dive
into so you might want to Circle back if
that was too fast
yeah is there any option to just like
one hot encode your entire vocabulary I
think this is my understanding of what
modern transformer-based models do
one hot encode the whole vocabulary
so well just say a bit more like what do
you what are you doing
of how large language models encode
individual words is they have a list of
all of their possible tokens they break
it down into tokens and then if you're
talking 337 you're just like
you have a vector of length the number
of tokens you have like a vocabulary of
like 50 000. and then you just want to
encode which token that is hmm
what we're about to do this so why don't
if I'll show you how they represent
things and let's see if it connects with
your question
because it is different yeah it is going
to be very different and the notion of
token and the notion of type is about to
get sort of complicated
right
before we do the technical part just a
little bit of context here about why I
think this is so exciting I'm a linguist
right and I was excited by these static
Vector representations of words but it
was also very annoying to me because
they give you one vector per word
whereas my experience of language is
that words have multiple senses and it
is hard to delimit where the senses
begin and end consider a verb like break
which I've worked on with my PhD student
Erica Peterson the vase broke that's one
sense maybe Dawn broke that's the same
form broke but that means something
different entirely different the news
broke again broke as the form there but
this sum being something more like was
published or appeared
Sandy broke the world record is very
unlike sin or the vase broke right now
it's like surpassing the limit
Sandy broke the law as a different sense
yet again that's some kind of
transgression the burglar broke into the
house that's break again but now with
the particle and that means something
different still the newscaster broke
into the movie Broadcast that means it
was interrupted
very different again we broke even
means I don't know we ended up back at
the same amount we started with
all so how many senses of break are here
if I was in the old mode of static
representation would I survive with one
break Vector for all of these examples
or would I have one per example type
type but then what about all the ones
that I didn't list here this and the
number of senses for break starts to
feel impossible to enumerate if you just
think about all the ways in which you
encounter this verb and there is some
metaphorical core that seems to run
through them but in the details these
senses are all very different
and this tells me that the sense of a
word like break is being modulated by
the context it is appearing in
and the idea that we would have one
fixed representation for it even if it's
learned from data is just kind of wrong
from the outset
here's another example we have a flat
tire
but what about flat beer flat note flat
surface
maybe they have some metaphorical core
but those feel like at least two to four
different senses for flat
throw a party throw a fight throw a ball
throw a fit oh very different senses
it's tragic to think we would have one
throw that was meant to cover all of
these examples right a crane caught a
fish
a crane picked up the steel beam
that might feel like a standard sort of
lexical ambiguity and so maybe you can
imagine that we have one vector for
Crane as a bird and one for a crane is a
machine
but is that going to work for the entire
vocabulary I suspect not I saw a crane
we wouldn't even know what Vector we
were dealing with there right which one
would we pick and now we have another
problem on our hands which is selecting
the static Vector based on contexts
right how are we going to do that and
this is a really deep thing it's not
just about the local kind of Morpho
syntactic context here what about are
there typos I didn't see any
so the sense of any there is like any
typos right versus are there bookstores
downtown I didn't see any now the sense
of any and the kind of elliptical stuff
that comes after it is any bookstores
and now I hope you can see that the
sense that words can have is modulated
by context in the most extended sense
and having fixed static representations
was never going to work in the face of
all of this diversity
we were never going to figure out how to
cut up the senses in just the right way
to get all of this data handled
correctly
and the vision of contextual
representation models is that you're not
even going to try to do all that hard
and boring stuff instead you are just
going to embrace the fact that every
word could take on a different sense
that is have a different representation
depending on everything that is
happening around it
and we won't have to decide then which
sense is in 1A and whether it's
different from one b and one C and so
forth we will just have all of these
token level
representations it will be entirely a
theory that is based in words as they
appear in context
for me as a linguist it is not
surprising at all that this turns out to
lead to lots of engineering successes
because it feels so deeply right to me
about how language works
uh brief history here I just want to be
dutiful about this make sure people get
credit where it's due November 2015 die
and lay that's a foundational paper
where they really did what is probably
the first example of language model
pre-training it's a cool paper to look
at it's complicated in some ways that
are surprising to us now and it is
certainly a Visionary paper
and then McCann at all this is a paper
from Salesforce research that's led by
at the time was read by Richard socher
who was a distinguished Alum of this
class
proud of that they developed the Cove
model where what they did is train
machine translation models and then the
inspired idea was that the Tran the
translation representations might be
useful for other tasks and again that
feels like the dawn of the notion of
pre-training contextual representations
and then Elmo came I mentioned Elmo last
time huge breakthrough massive
bi-directional lstms and they really
showed that that could lead to Rich
multi-purpose representations and that's
where you really feel everyone
reorienting their research toward these
kind of models that's not a Transformer
based one though that's by by lstms and
then we get GPT in June 2018
and Bert in October 2018.
um the bird paper was published a long
time after that but as I said before it
had already achieved massive impact by
the time it was published in 2019 or
whatever so that's why I've been giving
the months here because you can see it's
really there was this sudden uptake in
the amount of of interest in these
things that happened around this time
and that led to where we are now
another kind of interesting thing to
think about if you step back for the
context here is that we as a field have
been traveling from high bias models
where we decide a lot about how the data
should look and be processed toward
models that impose essentially nothing
on the world so if you go up into the
upper left here I'm just imagining a
model that's kind of in the old mode
where you have like your glove
representations of these three words and
to get a representation for the sentence
you just add up those representations
in doing that you have decided ahead of
time a lot of stuff about how those
pieces are going to come together I mean
you just said it was going to be
addition
which is almost certainly not correct
about how the world works but that so
that's a prototypical case of a high
bias decision
uh if you move over to the right here
that's a kind of recurrent neural
network
and here I've kind of decided that my
data will be processed left to right
I could learn a lot of different
functions in that space so it's much
more expressive much less biased in this
machine learning sense than this
solution here but I have still decided
ahead of time that I'm going to go left
to right
and this is another example these are
tree structured networks Richard socher
who I just mentioned was truly a Pioneer
in tree structured recursive neural
networks here I make a lot of decisions
about how the pieces can possibly come
together the rock as a unit constituent
separate from Rules which comes in later
and I'm just saying I know ahead of time
that the data will work that way if I'm
right it's going to give me a huge boost
because I don't have to learn those
details if I'm wrong though I might be
wrong forever
and I think that's actually that feeling
that you're wrong forever is what led to
this kind of thing happening so here
I've got kind of a bi-directional
recurrent model so now you can go left
right and right to left and all these
attention mechanisms that are gonna like
jump around in the linear string
and this is a true progression with what
happened with recurrent recursive sorry
recurrent neural networks go both
directions and add a bunch of attention
connections and that is kind of the
thing that caused everyone to realize oh
we should just connect everything to
everything else and go to the maximally
low biased version of this and just
assume that the data will teach us about
what's important to connect to what we
won't decide anything ahead of time so a
Triumph of saying I have no idea what
the world is going to be like I just
trust in my data and my optimization
the attention piece is really
interesting to me you know we used to
talk a lot about this in the course here
I have a sequence really not so good
and a common mode still common today is
that I might fit a classifier on this
final representation here to make a
sentiment decision
but people went on that journey I just
described where you think wait a second
if I'm just going to use this
won't I lose a lot of information about
the earlier words
I should have some way of like
connecting back and so what they did is
dot products essentially between the
thing that you're using for your
classifier and the previous States
that's what I've depicted here just as a
kind of way of scoring this final thing
with respect to the previous thing you
might normalize them a little bit and
then form what was called the context
Vector this is like the attention
representation and what I've done here
is build these links back to all these
previous States and that turned out to
be incredibly powerful and when you read
the title of the paper attention is all
you need what they are doing is saying
you don't need lstm connections and
recurrent connections and stuff the
sense in which attention is all you need
is the sense in which they're saying all
you needed was these connections that
you were adding on to the top of your
earlier models
and maybe they were right but certainly
it has taken over the field
another important idea here that might
often be overlooked is just this notion
that we should model the sub parts of
words and again I can't resist a
historical note here if you look back at
the Elmo paper what they did to embrace
this Insight is incredible they had
character level representations
and then they fit all these convolutions
on top of all those character level
representations was essentially like
ways of pooling together subparts of the
word and then they form a representation
of at the top that's like the average
plus the concatenation of all of these
different convolutional layers and the
result of this is a vocabulary that does
latently have information about
characters and subparts of words as well
as words in it
I feel that that's deeply right right
and this is like a space in which you
can capture lots of things like how talk
is similar to talking and is similar to
talked and you know all that stuff that
a simple unigram parsing would miss is
latently represented in this space
but
the vocabulary for Elmo is like a
hundred thousand words so that's a
hundred thousand embedding space that I
need to have it's absolutely gargantuan
and
it's still the case that if you process
real data you have to Unk out that is
Mark is unknown most of the words you
encounter because the language is
incredibly complicated and a hundred
thousand doesn't even come close to
covering all the tokens that you
encounter in the world
and so again we have this kind of Galaxy
brain moment where I guess the field
says forget all that
and what you do instead is tokenize your
data so that you just split apart words
into their sub word tokens if you need
to
so here I've got an example with the
Bert tokenizer this isn't too surprising
that comes out looking kind of normal
but if you do encode me
notice that the word encode has been
split into two tokens
and if you do Snuffleupagus
you get one two three four five six
seven tokens six or seven from that
because it doesn't know what the word is
and so what it does is not Unk it out
but rather split it apart into a bunch
of different pieces and the result is
the really startling thing that
bert-like models have only thirty
thousand words in their vocabulary
but their words in the sense that
they're these sub word tokens
now this was going to be tragically bad
in the realm where we were doing static
word representations because I'm going
to have a vector for n u
and have no sense in which it was
participating in the larger part of
Snuffleupagus
but we're talking about contextual
models so even if these are the tokens
the model is going to see the full
sequence
and we can hope that it reconstructs
something like the word from all the
pieces that it encountered certainly we
could hope that for something like
encode
and we take this for granted now but
it's deeply insightful to me and it had
you know incredibly freeing in terms of
the engineering resources that you need
but it does depend on Rich contextual
representations
and then another notion positional
encoding
so we have all these tokens or maybe you
know subparts of words
in addition to representing things using
a traditional static embedding space
like a glove one that's what I put with
these light gray boxes here
we'll also represent sequences with
positional encodings which will just
keep track of where the token appeared
in the sequence I'm processing
and what that means is that the word
Rock here
occurring in position two
will have a different representation if
rock appears in position 47 in the
string
it'll be kind of the same word but also
partly a different word
and that's another way in which you're
embracing the fact that all of these
representations are going to be
contextual
this is an interesting story for me
because I've been slow to realize what
maybe the whole field already knew that
this is incredibly important how you do
this positional encoding really matters
for how models perform and that's why in
fact it's like one of these early topics
here that we'll talk about next time
and then of course
another guiding idea here is that we are
going to do massive scale pre-training I
mentioned this before we're going to
have these contextual models with all
these tiny little parts of words in them
all in sequences with positional
encodings and we are going to train at
an incredible scale that's that same
story of word to that glove through GPT
and then on up to gpt3 I mentioned this
before and some magic happens as you do
this on more and more data with larger
and larger models
and then finally this is related
this Insight that instead of starting
from scratch for my machine learning
models
I should start with a pre-trained one
and fine-tune it for particular tasks
right we saw this a little bit in the
pre-transformer era the standard mode
was to take love or word to VEC
representations and have them be the
inputs to something like an RNN and then
the RNN would learn and instead of
having to learn the embedding space from
scratch it would start in this really
interesting space and that is actually a
kind of learning of contextual
representations because what happens if
the glove representations are updated is
that they all shift around and the
network kind of pushes them around so
that you get different senses from for
them in context
and then again the Transformer thing
just takes that to the Limit
and that is the mode that you'll operate
in for the first homework I've put this
from 2018 onwards we have this thing
where I hope you can make it out at the
bottom you load in Bert and you just put
a classifier on top of it
and you learn that classifier for your
sentiment task say and that actually
updates the Burt parameters and the burp
parameters help you do better at your
task and in particular they might help
you generalize to things that are
sparsely represented in your task
specific training data because they've
learned so much about the world in their
pre-training phase
I put that for 2018 onwards I'm a little
worried that we're moving into a future
in which fine-tuning is just again using
an open AI API but you all will
definitely learn how to do much more
than this even if you fall back on doing
this at some point where now what you're
doing is some lightweight version of
fine-tuning a massive model like gpt3
same mental model there it's just that
the starting point knows so much about
language in the world compared even to
the Burt model up here
um
those are the guiding ideas a pause
questions comments what's on your minds
yeah uh going back to the support uh
splitting of of the longer work is there
an infusion we are imposing on spreading
a particular way or is that also a part
of Market driven by that one itself oh
yeah so what gets imposed as a modeling
bias in that sense when you do the
tokenization is that the question yeah
potentially a lot I left this out for
reasons of time but there are a bunch of
different schemes that you can run for
doing that sub word tokenization you'll
see this as you read papers and as I
talk word piece there's byte pairing
coding there's a unigram language model
all of them are attempts to learn kind
of optimal way to tokenize the data
based on things that tend to co-occur a
lot together
but it's definitely a meaningful step
yeah and so like for example as someone
who's interested in the morphology of
languages word forms and you all might
this could be a cool multilingual angle
if you think about language of very rich
morphology you might have an intuition
that you want a tokenization scheme that
reproduces the morphology of that
language that splits a big word with all
its suffixes say down into things that
look like the actual pieces that as you
recognize them and then you could think
well the best of these schemes should
come close to that right and that could
be an important and useful bias that you
impose
can you elaborate on what happens when
we do fine tuning to the original model
like does it change or just it adds
additional layers to it or like what
actually happens with my fine tuning
what happens when you fine-tune as usual
with these questions there's like an
easy answer and a hard answer so the
easy answer is that you are simply back
propagating whatever error signal you
got from your you know output comparison
with the true label back through all the
parameters of the model and in principle
that could mean that you know as you
fine tune on your sentiment task you are
updating all of the parameters even the
the pre-trained bird ones and then of
course there are variants of that where
you update just some of the burp
parameters while leaving others Frozen
and so forth but the idea is you have a
smart initialization that's the Bert
initialization and then you kind of
adjust the whole thing to be really good
at your task
what really happens there
that's a deep question right that could
actually connect with the explainability
stuff like what adjustments are
happening to the network and which ones
are useful which ones could even be
detrimental which ones are causing you
to overfit are there lightweight
versions of the fine tuning that would
be better and more robust and get a
better balance from the pre-training and
the task specific thing
and that just shows you fine-tuning is
an art and a science all at once
sure
so
do we also control like that influence
of the fine tuning data set over the
original model again
can we control it in a way that oh chain
just change the model a little bit or
change the original model completely or
let's see what's the right metaphor you
could control it
the same way that you could control a
kind of out of control car when you have
a steering wheel and you have an
accelerator and a brake but if they're
all kind of you're not sure how they
work
um yeah you can try and as you get
better at the task as you get better at
driving the vehicle you'd have more fine
control but it's a art and a science at
the same time I'm actually hoping you
know that Sid he's going to do a
Hands-On session with us next week and
then he imparts some of his own hard-won
lessons to you about how to drive these
things because he's really been in the
trenches doing this with large models
but you know you have your learning rate
and your Optimizer and other things you
can fiddle with and hope that it steers
in the direction you want
yeah if we use tree structures right now
to represent like syntax I guess my
question is why don't they work super
well for language models and like I
guess the sentiment that you have was
like oh kind of just like put attention
towards anything and see what works I
guess why is that the sentiment in
linguistics then as well
great question my personal perspective
is that probably all the trees that we
have come up with are kind of wrong
and as a result we were actually making
it harder for our models because we were
putting them in this bad initial State
and so the mode I've moved into is to
think let's use the Transformer
something that's much more like this
totally free form and then use
explainability methods to see if we can
see what tree structures they've induced
because those might be closer to the
true tree structures of language and
another aspect of this is that I feel
like there's not even for a given
sentence one structure there could be
one for semantics one for syntax one for
other things and so we want those all
simultaneously represented and again
these powerful models we're talking
about could do that and so then they
become devices for helping us learn what
the right structures are as opposed to
us imposing them
yeah
numbers are important part of language
how tokenization works for numbers
because it's digits its words the same
meaning different meaning uh is it in
the same domain or it's
something otherwise oh I love this this
is a great example of something that
sounds small but could be a wonderful
final paper and turns out to be hard and
deep how do you represent numbers if
you've got a wordpiece tokenizer do you
get it down to all the digits do you
leave them as big chunks do you do it
based on a strong bias that you have
about like this is the tens place this
is the hundreds place what do you do
yeah wonderful question to ask and I am
absolutely positive that that low level
tokenization choice will influence
whether or not your model can learn to
do basic arithmetic say
yeah
and so a paper that evaluated a bunch of
schemes in a way that was insightful and
important you know on real mathematical
abilities could really help us
understand which models will be
intrinsically limited and in turn how to
develop better ones I love it
yeah uh on this slide they have the
that's titled attention you've shown
your scores as best products with the
final uh the word against all the other
previous ones well I picked the final
why not the first one
or all of them attention is all you need
this is a perfect transition so yeah you
should do all of them that's like the
what they mean by the title of the paper
yes do it all self-attention means
attending everything to everything else
so this is a perfect transition we're
out of time 420 next time we will dive
into the Transformer we'll resolve the
questions that we got back there you'll
see much more of these attention
connections yeah we're really queued up
now to dive into the technical parts